> Jake Archibald: Can you all hear me? Right,
so, I'm not getting a whole lot of anything
on the screen. (Hey ... oh, no ... here we
go. And I think we are good to go. Right.
We go on the screen, brilliant, hello, we've
come a long way haven't we in the past 20
years since the '90s, I mean, back then you
would have some friends over, it'd be going
great, then two of your friends would start
having a disagreement involving the release
gait of ghost busters, but then it starts
to get heated, none of them are backing down,
the mood of the dinner party is at stake,
but it's okay, for you hold aloft the answer,
for you are the proud owner of Microsoft Cinemania.
Giving you instant access to the history of
cinema. Well, it's not really instant, first
you must go to the room with the computer
in and turn it on, and then the fan starts
whirring, you get that friendly static crackle
as the CRT monitor whirs into action, windows
3.1 slowly boots up. Then you get your desktop,
eventually. And it does this (Horn sound)
and that really sets expectations we are dealing
with an operating system that thinks that
booting successfully is a fanfare worthy moment
(Applause) and by the power of multimedia
C ROM you veal that ghost busters was release
in the 1984, you did that in under ten minutes,
the dinner party is saved. The web changed
everything, with the web you get information
instantly, no installation, they looked out
of date the CDs almost instantly, having separate
apps for these things became weird, the stuff
ton internet was better, built with new interconnected
with the modern world in run, the browser
Runtime replaced more my native App, office
tooling, code editors, native apps became
the exception, if you look at the top ten
selling laptops on Amazon they include chrome
books that's how secondary native apps are,
though that's not true on mobile. The native
apps still rule, because they build to the
strength of the platform and a lot of the
web predates that, some of the web is hostile
to mobile. This is a creative agency that
I won't name; this is what you get if you
visit their site.
> Choosing your creative agency isn't like
buying a pair of shoes, so why group make
yourself Coffee and visit our site on real
screen. They're kind over right, I never had
a shoe tell me to Fuck off and come back when
I have real feet. You can see the things they're
expert in, which includes, responsive sites,
of course (Laughing) the more worrying case
the sites are simply hostile to just the mobile
web, not just the mobile platform, this is
a horrible situation, the user has gone to
these sites in a browser following a deep
link rather than sending them the thing they
want, we send them to another thing where
they can download a thing to install a thing
that can run that Macon train the thing they
originally wanted somewhere in in the interface.
It's not a good United Nations experience,
it's one developers think is good to get you
after the web to the native app. Think about
the native apps you use and rely on, this
that is where the web is failing what caused
that failure, what features do they have that
can make it impossible to replicate on the
web. I use these apps often, or they can't
be done on the web because of push notification,
that is vital for the apps in yellow, they
tell me someone sent me something, or something
happens in the background when the App isn't
open,I rarely use trip it, I forget I have
it. Then it'll send me a notification that
a flight is delayed or canceled. Background
Sync, from downloading pod cast to sending
an e‑mail late their failed to send at the
time, which sends to off line, I depend on
this for more apps that I realize for playing
music, checking where my hotel is, looking
up a meeting location, I continue want to
depend on connectivity for these things, we
need better performance and integration to
the O several, battery staps, accounting information,
the web can't do these, and that's a bug,
what gives me hope is that these are bugs
that are getting fixed not just being thought
about, code is landing to fix these things,
and these are the ones I want to talk about
today these require something new, background
Sync, that happen in the background, push
notification are received and dealt with in
the background. Off line, doesn't run in the
background but requires context to run before
pages, and that thing is the service worker.
And this is the Spec. That bit got a round
applause at GoogleIO (Applause) don't patronize,
me, I could of dressed it up a bit. I like
what graphic cards into in this present, they're
just circuit boards, but they need to sort
of dress themselves up to make them look like
the must have for people. Even though they
don't do anything on their own. The boxes
they come in are amazing in this kind of sub
deviant arts craft, you get the usual sort
of sexist nonsense you get with gaming, you
always get things like the hideous off string
of Sh reck and Yoda and also teenage mutant
Ninja dog. So in this vain, I present to you
the service worker! (Applause) that's Memrod
using his evil pow tore control browser feature.
We need a logo, stop me. This is something
being worked on between Google Mozilla Sam
sung. It has no Dom access, unlike a shared
worker it can exist without a reference to
it and shuts down when not in used this is
the gabbinge background context we need. It's
in Bruce tore day, you'll need COMCanary,
you'll need go about about flags and enable
experimental browser feature and restart.
If chrome isn't your thing you can use fire
fox nightly, go to about Config and enable
service worker and give the Bruce ear restart.
I'm going to stick with canary, Google played
for my flight and hoe it will, it would be
rude not to. And the debugging tool is forever
ahead. If you want to know what support or
sub features, it's service worker ready and
tells you which browser support what. It's
the foundation for the others, off line suffers
from the same misconceptions as progressive
enhancement, I think, people say my App doesn't
need to work off line because my users have
permanent internet connectivity, but it's
not just about zero connectivity, it's about
treating the network as an enhancement, when
user clicks a link to your site, the URL start
a navigation, a document is created, but we
have to go to network to get the data for
that, that can take a long time, it will come
back eventually, we can't rend E. we have
to send request for the Java, the images,
as these come back we can start to render,
but the sub resource trigger other sub resources,
fonts, images used in the CSS, when they come
back we get towards our find render. As a
practical example I'll take train ‑‑ it's
a responsive site, I was on a train when I
started building it I had a moment of zero
inspiration. But let's load it on a phone
that's 250‑kilo births fifteen‑year‑old
me would have kill you for a 256 kill birth
con next, not the best today but far from
the worst. So, three, two, one, go. We get
the first render, that wasn't JavaScript dependent
.
we get content after 5 seconds that's from
Flickr, those images are 200 K each, that's
what it gave me if I wanted to coverer this
density. First image through, after thirty‑seconds,
other images start loading, after what seems
like years, we get the full render. Now, that
video wasn't real‑time, I had to cut it
down, it took so long, those are the correct
figures, we can compress the images better,
we can do things to insure the top images
load first,I just took what Flickr gave me.
We are still beating native, the equivalent
is the visit the App store, download, it's
a slow user experience, but native kicks our
ass on the second visit it used that initial
download and install cash loads of stuff,
we have the browser cash, but the whole internet
is fighting for that, if we change one line
in CSS or java script, we change the file
name, we break the cash,we like to deploy
often, we're breaking the cash office. This
page register for a service worker allowing
us to do something about the second load.
Registration estruation is simple, miter JavaScript
like, this you can also scope it to an area
of your origin, and that's use informal you
have single origin with many apps, like Google
does with calendar and stuff like that. The
default scope is the whole origin, which we'll
use here, it returns a promise so you can
find out if it works or not. You can register
for a service worker on 750 DPS, the service
worker is so power it would p a disaster it
fall boss a man in the middle is a good place
to butt demo stuff and local host is exempt
for development. Console log, listen for install
events, service worker for the first time,
so let's see that in action. First, I'm going
to go to service worker internal, which is
where our debugging stuff is living at the
moment, as you can see there's nothing there.
Then I'll open the train site, a dead version
of it . As you can see on the bottom corner
there, our service worker is successfully
registered F we go to service worker internals
there, it is, there's our console log, we
can launch Dev tools, we can also set break
points run stuff on the console, etc… If
we fast forward time a bit, the service worker
terminates, that's not a bug, it's just not
needed at the moment, closes to conserve memory.
And congratulations, at that point, you're
now wielding the power of the service worker,
but what did that actually get us? Nothing.
(Laughing) but, wait, oh, my God, it's actually
a good thing that it does nothing. The unapologetically
made it good. Compare it to App cash, if you
give manifest, and that manifest only contains
the words cash manifest,I would expect to
go from this to this said no one ever in the
world. So, we didn't want to do that, service
worker doesn't do anything unless you tell
it to do something, App Cache broke a lot
of eggs and failed to make a omelet, has the
right ingredients, routing fetching cashing,
updates and version control,blouse first reverse
the piles of implicit behavior, which are,
of course, guarded by the army of robot wasps.
If you've used that Cache before you'll know
what I mean. We sort it out, without getting
stung. This is the extensible web. Don't ask
don't take fish, ask for a fisher rod, but
take the fish as well. We need both high and
low level AIs, the service worker is event
driven we've seen install, it's also fetch,
this fires for any navigation for your scope,
but also for any sub resource from that page.
In service worker internals, we're going to
start off the service worker, inspect it,
navigate to our train site, you see as soon
as we navigate we hit the break point many
if net fetch, we get one for the CSS, we skip
from there, we'll get the logo, the JavaScript,
we rendered before JavaScript because we care
about performance, get API call to Flikr.
And then get all the image requests coming
in. But, hey, the cool bit is, this is ‑‑ this
is an event, like other vents like clique,
touch start, key down, you can present the
default and do something else Y. can respond
with something else. Responses can be created
manually, give it some texts, and if do we,
that the page gives us this to this. But the
swears interesting thing here S. we delivered
that without going to the network at all,
making it the first off line demo of the talk
only almost halfway through, but we can do
better than that. When the browser discover
the service worker for first time, we'll send
it to the network, get it to make load of
requests and get responses it might with fast
it might be slow,the network is not predictable,
we're not disrupting the user they already
have the page open. If our response comes
back we'll put them in the Cache, this pre‑Cache
method is what native would do with an initial
install back age, we do it in the background
without disrupting the user, the loot page
template, JavaScript, all the stat tick stuff,
when we get a request for one of those things,
we'll just get it from the Cache, the uncertainty
of the network is no learn our problem, this
is simple thanks to the cashing API, full
control of the Cache in the install event
from earlier, we get this vent ‑‑ and
we can pass a promise into there that extends
the installation process, use to indicate
success and failure as well. Here we're going
to create a Cache, give a name, and then add
stuff to it, our static has sets, if any of
these fail, the whole operation fails. And,
service worker won't control pages, so if
the install succeeds we know we have these
thing in the Cach oh, there are deopinion
Dennis, it's not thee canary yet, there's
a poly fill, the proper implementation in
a few weeks. How do we use these Cache items,
responds with Cac hade.match, it will find
a response that matches that request, it's
done by method, URL, similar to the browser
Cach e if there's no match you'll get no back,
if we get no, we can send something else,
what should we do instead, we could send a
fall back entry, what if we want to try the
network, to do this we need the make a request
using JavaScript. In 1999, Microsoft engineers
were design ago new excitingAPI, what should
they call it, it contained abbreviations,
initialisms, they shouldn't decide if it should
be all caps or just the first letter like
getElement by ‑‑ so they did both XMLHttpReques
the ‑‑ restricted to HTTP but it isn't,
and request, you get a request object back,
yet you don't. We tried to modernize it is
a bit, fetching some JSON, is verboten, we've
been patching this API for fifteen years,
I do not want to use this AI when it's old
enough to drink. Thankfully, the fetch back
by Mozilla, it gives lower level control,
weave already seen some of it. Lower APSI
usually easier to use than higher level one,
HHR is so bad, it's not true here, the equivalent
to this in Fetch Fetch URL gives you a promise,
pass it how you want, gives you a promise,
done. This is a forward thinking API, arrow
functions make it easier, Async functions
can make it a one liner if you want. To answer
the question, how do we send this request
to network, fetch. So what improvements does
this give us, 3, 2, 1, go. We reverend almost
instantly, we get content after a couple of
seconds, we still go to the network, but our
JavaScript rivered so much quicker, we're
able to start it so much sooner, still a sad
sorry ‑‑ let's fix that. When there's
a request for a Flickr, if we have it in the
cash it will return from the cash over wise
we go to the network, when when we get response
back, we'll send to the cash and the page,
this is also good for Avatars, things you
want to Cache as you go along, we're going
to special case URLs that end in static Flickr.com,
take the request, try to take frit the darks
fetch it from the network, add it to our Cache,
send it to the browser, need be careful, we're
adding to the cash for every image request,
we'll need the garden at some point. For now,
how does that improve things, 3, 2, 3e 1,
go. We render quickly, content comes through
quickly, this time we have images, all of
the images weave seen already, but not this
one at the top that's new, that comes through
in 11 seconds, and that's pretty good, but
we're still dependent on network for the initial
API call that tells us which images to display,
let's fix that. So this one's a little bit
different, the page does a fetch for the API,
via the service worker,as everything does,
it also goes straight to the Cache, because
pages can access the Cache too, it'll render
with it, that will trigger the requests for
the old images that is also in the cash the
service worker goes to the network, gets data
back, we do what we do with the images, wend
it both to the cash and the page, this is
a good point to clean up the Cache, with this
pattern it makes two requests, once from the
we shall question, once from the network,
we get to render quickly with all content
but provide up to date content when we find
it, the best native apps find it, very few,
but the best ones do. Here's where we're at
now, we also want to special case K PI.Flickr.com.
In that case we'll do, this I'm not going
to go through this line by line, this is fetching
data, returning it to the browser, this start
of Gnarly bit in the middle, pausing data
from Flickr, and removing ones from the cash
that we don't need anymore this is a little
bit Gnarly with promises ES 78 functions make
it neater, that's the service worker ‑‑ this
makes two request requests so one over on
the page side,www.to the Cache, one to network.
Afterf the respond come in after the Cac he,
we'll update, we'll know an error if they
both fail provide data. If the Cache but network
fails, we fail silently. That was probably
too much code to show on slides. But my point
is we're expressing complex behavior using
small amounts of code, and the effect of that,
let's remind ourself where we started, first
visit, takes quite a long time to get the
first render, just over a second, then content
comes in after over five seconds and then
we're waiting forever for the images. Of with
service worker and the code we've written
to manager the network and Caching, 3, 2,
1, go,we have what looks like a complete view
rendered quickly, new data comes in after
a few seconds, doesn't disrupt the user, we
get the image, we shaved a second off our
first render, over 30 seconds for what looks
like a complete view. You can get content
on the screen in a fraction of a second whether
you have a fast, slow or no connection, it
doesn't matter this catches up to native.
First up, push, something I depend on for
many apps before we look at code, going to
give a live demo a go, which is (Laughing)
see how this goes. Remi, could you help me
with this? So ... Remy, you're going to send
a chat in there, but not until we have something
on the screen.
> Huh… I got it by the way…
> Fine ‑‑
> It's pretty good.
> You’re enjoying your morning so far, was
breakfast good?
> Yes
> I didn't breakfast, I was afraid I might
throw it up. (Laughing)
> Oh, there we go. This is a simple chat App,
this is running in an internal build of Chromium,
but based on actual speck work. If you could
type in any message in there.
> Oh, that's nice, thank you whoever tweeted
that, oh, that's lovely, no one tweet anything
rude right now.
> How's the WiFi holding up? I guess it's
‑‑
> Let's refresh that. Go again.Ed oh, that's
a disaster, isn't it I'll refresh this one
as well.
> Go again, if not, we'll just babe don it
‑‑
> You say don't swear,
> Yes, but it's great because it's not going
to display, so ... well, agreement tweets,
which is a good sign. Oh, this worked like
five minutes ago. No, we might just have to
aBonn don it. I'm going to drop on to roaming
and see if that helps.
> Restart Chrome
oh, that's a good idea. That normally fixing
everything. We're using fire fox here to send
the messages, so I can always blame them.
Give it one more go, if not, we'll just bane
don it. Yes,thank you Remy! (Applause) no,
stay. That's ‑‑ we've seen that happen
before, this is nothing new, what I'm going
to do now is I'm going to close Chromium completely,
int browsers not open at all. No recent apps
on. So ... many Remy would you care to send
another message. Now, what we're getting here,
this is a push notification using open web
features, and completely native notification,
the browser was closed started up the service
worker in the background and we got a push
notification, because we're using native notification,
it appeared on multifamily watch as well just
using the open web. (Applause) Remy's birth
day as well! Can we switch over to the laptop,
is that possible (Happy birthday, to you ‑‑ happy
birthday to you. Happy birthday, happy birth
dear Remy, happy birthday to you! (Applause)
> Brilliant. So ... right, I'm hideously running
over now, the way we coded that, it's just
a standard, from your page, you register for
push messaging, we'll give you the details
like the ID and end point where to send messages,
but when that actually, when that's called
you gel get an vent in the service worker,
you'll get to do what you want at this point,
look at data, update cache, show notification,
once again, you get to did what you want,
in that case you can navigate to that page,
refocus an existing tab. Background sink is
similar, you don't need a service operator
for that, sometime late your fire an vent
in the service worker to do something for
me that I was unable to do earlier. These
things require use permission, of course,
they'll be told of this.
> You have ten minutes.
> I have ten minutes, oh,I'm going to tell
you about how to code push and Sythisc, then
(Laughing) okay, how did that demo work, Jack?
Well, I'll tell you. From the page you call
navigator.serviceWorker.ready that gives you
the registration ‑‑ navigator.serviceWorker
‑‑ on our registration we call push.register,
that gives you the details and you post those
to the service, you'll associate that with
the current use their will give you the end
point information where you'll send the information.
For home, GSM, Google Cloud messaging, every
browser can use their own, you'll need an
account set up with the different push messaging
providers the data you'll send to these things
will be exactly the same, you'll just have
to know which way you're sending it, which
will be a URL, when the user receives a message,
you get a push event and you have a look to
see what kind of data, I'm going to react
to that, I'm going to do ‑‑ after this
I'll show a notification. Something, this
is something that native, even the really
best native apps, they get it wrong, often
I'll get a tweet, I won't notice it when it
around arrive, on the under ground I'll see
the notification, I'll click et, I'll get
nothing because they haven't cached that data
off line. You get an vent when you get a click
notification and you do what you want, usually
navigating to the page, give a we to enumerate
the client, which there pages within your
scope, look at theme them, see if they're
focused, hidden, hang on, there's already
a window that has focus, so I don't need to
show a notification or I don't need to navigate
anywhere,I can determine that stuff ahead
of time. What about background Sync, lets
you wake up the service worker at some vague
point in the future to do whatever you want
this is a bit similar to push, it's a lot
simpler, if you try to send an e‑mail but
the user has no connection, the user is down
it fails, you can saver it somewhere, IDB
or another cache AI, then register for a Sync
event, that triggers a permission dialogue,
then, sometimes later when the user has good
connectivity, you get a Sync vent, if the
ID empty in‑box, get the out box and try
to send all the e‑mails, in this pattern,
it works similar to installer event, if you
pass the event ‑‑ it will reschedule.
If we fail to send the e‑mail it will be
scheduled for later this is registering for
a single Sync event, you ask for ones on an
interval as well, use updating train did that
that that the background, the ‑‑ is a
minimum, when things happen determined heuristically,
if you register for a Sync once day and we
know the user looks allot your App like about
9:00 in the morning, we can schedule the Sync
for 10‑9, and coalescing it with other sink
events. With service worker we gain a lot
of the features that make native superior,
butane the bits that keep the web super your,
the instant on, no install required, open
platform. Chrome is going to start chipping
this stuff this year, it's already if canary,
it'll go to stable this year, fire fox actively
developing, Microsoft is investigating it,
we haven't heard anything from apple, but
that's not unusual at this stage, it's designed
to be an enhancement, I mean no browser is
going to have it on the first visit
> Have to prepare, use basic object detection
you can give the benefit to the browsers that
support it, which is a lot of users in chrome's
case. It doesn't turn push messages into ‑‑ it
gives you nothing for free, but it treats
you like an adult, gifts you the moving parts
and do what you want, make things faster,
work off line, create new features trance
code a video former using streams, turn build
a client side Wik I, do it in a way this'
unique your App, the way that gives the best
user experience. I am heavily biased. I think
this changes what the web is capable. Let's
build some cool stuff with it. Thank you very
much (Applause)